[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZOLTAN ARATO: My
name is Zoltan Arato,
I'm a product manager
of Google Cloud IT Core.
Let me also introduce
Preston Holmes--
head of IoT Solutions--
for Google also.
He's going to be on
stage with us shortly.
So, today we are going to talk
about a specific type of IoT
applications.
Applications those involve,
of course, IoT devices,
mobile or web applications,
and-- very importantly-- also,
users.
And you are going
to see that users
will be an important component
in this presentation.
And as part of
this presentation,
we will review, sort of,
the theoretical background,
the business context.
And then we will show you a
tool box using Cloud IoT Core.
And some of the Firebase
product, how you could
implement these use-cases.
And we will finish
with the demo.
So, both Preston and
I, have been working in
around IoT projects for
almost five years, now.
And we have seen
two main patterns
emerging when it comes
to IoT to use-cases.
The first one is--
I like to call them--
data ingestion intensive, or
data ingestion heavy use-cases.
In these use-cases,
there are many devices
sending a lot of data upstream.
So, typically, the bandwidth
requirement upstream
is much higher than downstream.
And usually, these
are applications
for monitoring or analytics.
And I mentioned
that users will be
an important part of our talk.
And in these use-cases,
usually there
are less personas involved.
On the other hand, the
other type of application--
we usually see when
working with customers--
we like to call it complex
application logic use-cases.
So, in these use-cases--
or applications--
the data model is
usually more complex.
There is a similar need--
in terms of bandwidth
requirements--
upstream and downstream.
And that's because these
applications are not
only about receiving
data from devices,
but also controlling them.
So, most of the time, this
complex business logic
is used to determine some sort
of change that is required
to be performed on the devices.
And then sent back these
commands or configurations
to the devices.
And what makes the
implementation of these
use-cases challenging is
the multiple personas--
sort of in the mix--
or having to interact
with these deployments.
So, when it comes to these
complex application logic use
cases, typically these
are the building blocks
that we see as required
for implementation.
So, mobile and web applications
to control the devices
and see their actual state.
The devices, of course.
Device management
capabilities meaning
like, Credential Management,
grouping, updating
the firmware, of the devices.
Cloud services, data
management tools in the Cloud.
Or storage solutions
or computing solutions.
User management, so, most
commonly, an identity
provider to store your users
and then handle your users.
We already touched upon
command and control.
So, the capability to interact
with the devices, to be able to
control them.
And last-- but not
least-- sensor data
aggregation and visualization.
So you want to see--
or in these use-cases,
users want to see--
sensor data or aggregated
data of one device
for multiple devices.
And there is a
horizontal layer, here.
So all these building
blocks are used
by various users or personas.
And these users may have very
different access control needs
or limitations.
And this is going
to be a focus--
in our talk-- how to implement
authorization for these users.
Because we have seen
that, many times,
this is very challenging.
So, depending on how
the business is run,
the same building
blocks are used.
And there are three
main categories here.
We are going to see
examples for each.
So B2B, business to business.
B2B2B-- there is
another B added here--
and B2B2C.
And the first B is always the
IoT or Cloud Service provider.
So in our case,
it's Google Cloud.
And then the second
B is our customer.
And, in many times, our
customers operate the service--
some sort of Sas service--
in IoT Solution, using
our infrastructure.
And sell these services either
to businesses or consumers.
So to give you an
example of all of these,
probably the B2B
scenario is the simplest,
in terms of implementation.
And probably the
best example would
be a connected factory, or
connected manufacturing line.
So a factory with
connected PLCs.
When it comes to implementing
these use-cases--
based on these business models--
usually, it's enough to
use the resources provided
by the Cloud service provider.
So, case in this
case, Google Cloud.
So these are existing
resources, or building blocks.
And implementing these
use-cases can rely only
on these components.
And, very importantly, there are
no end users in B2B use cases.
This is a little bit
more complicated,
the B2B2B scenario.
Maybe the best way to describe
this category of use-cases
is through an example.
So imagine a connected truck
fleet management system.
A company that provides this
truck fleet management services
as excess service, and
let's say they also
sell hardware that
their customers can
install in their trucks.
Or it can be other
vehicle, as well.
And there are end
users in this scenario.
So, if you think about the
customers of the Sas provider--
the connected truck fleet
management system provider--
those users are end users.
So for instance, a driver or
operator of a given fleet.
And we have to realize
that in these use-cases,
there is a really wide spectrum
of roles and permissions.
So just to reflect on
my previous example,
a drive has really
different access rights
compared to the manager
of a whole fleet.
The B2B2C scenario is
a little bit simpler,
but similar to the previous one.
Probably, this is the most
familiar to all of you.
A good example would be a
smart lighting solution.
Really, the only
difference here,
is that the end
users are consumers.
And in these
use-cases, there are
multiple personas, and roles,
and permission requirements.
But, typically, less
than in case of B2B2B.
I wanted to show you
a real world example.
And it's very relevant
here, in San Francisco.
So, you might have seen these
scooters out on the streets.
These are connected
scooters, so they
are connected to the internet.
And there is a
corresponding app,
or there is an app
you need to use if you
want to ride the scooters.
And there is a very
complex business logic
behind the service.
So-- if you think about it--
the user of the
application and the scooter
needs to gain access
rides to the scooter just,
for the period of that
person is riding the scooter.
So this is a pretty complex
business logic, here.
And they are actually using
Google Cloud Services.
Just to give you a summary of
some of these various business
models, or sort
of overview them.
So, in all cases,
the manufacturer
is some kind of device
maker or an OEM.
That's common in
all three scenarios.
When it comes to the
owner of the devices--
so who owns the device--
in case of B2B, this is trivial.
It's called customer of
the Cloud Service Provider,
so it's a corporate
owner or an operator.
And there is no end
user in case of B2B.
In the other two categories,
there are end users.
In case of B2B2B,
the interesting thing
is that the owner is
also a corporate owner--
or operator-- but the
end user is different.
So they don't necessarily
own the hardware.
So, just to reflect back on the
truck fleet management system,
this hardware-- or
these tracking devices--
might be installed on trucks.
But let's say the
driver of the truck
doesn't necessarily
own the device.
In case of B2B2C, this
is a little bit simpler.
Because in these use-cases,
usually the owner and the end
user are the same person.
So think about the
connected light example.
All right, so when it comes
to the implementation--
and we will go into the
actual details very soon--
but just to review, that
there are two main layers
of the sort of,
back implementation
of these use-cases.
Application and infrastructure,
just like in other systems.
This is true in IoT, as well.
So what's typical
for infrastructure
is that usually there
are Cloud Services.
And these are pre-existing
building blocks.
So, for instance, like, Compute
Engine instances-- or devices--
but there are many of
them in Google Cloud.
What is common is that there
is a service called Cloud IAM.
And Cloud IAM controls what
sort of permissions a given
user has on what resources.
And in this layer, the
resources are obviously
defined by the Cloud
Service Provider.
So in our case, it's
defined by Google.
And typically, in
case of B2B use-cases,
the implementation is
heavier in this layer.
So there is less need
for an application layer.
Because you can usually use
these pre-existing building
blocks.
The application layer.
This is where the
business logic--
most of the business logic--
is implemented.
This is where the command and
control decisions are made.
And this is the layer
responsible for transmitting
these decisions to the
infrastructure layer.
We can look at this layer as the
digital version of the business
model, of a given use-case.
And this layer is
usually thicker
in case of the B2B2B
and B2B2C use-cases.
Now, an interesting
question is that, of course,
these two layers live together.
So they are implemented
together and both exist.
And there is always some sort
of overlap between the two.
And the question is, how do
we crossover between the two
layers?
How do we bridge between
a device that only exists
as an infrastructure piece?
And its authorization
is controlled by IAM.
So how do we provide access to
this device for a user that--
for instance, only exists in a
third party identity provider--
which can be even
external to Google.
And the good news is
that Google has solutions
to solve these problems.
And we have tools to implement
these authorisation control
mechanisms.
And so I would like to
invite Preston on stage
to tell more how to do that.
PRESTON HOLMES:
Thank you, Zoltan.
So, we talked about
the general cases
of the infrastructure layer
and the application layer.
So if we look first at some
of the infrastructure ways
that we can apply IAM
in Cloud IoT Core.
Which is our primary service for
authorizing, and identifying,
and securely connecting
devices that exist out
in sort of the field to cloud.
This service has a set of
IAM permissions and roles
that let you define
who can do what
with the logical
device resources that
are stored in IoT Core.
And, like many cloud
IAM permissions,
these can be applied at
different scopes of influence.
So this is an example of
where these permissions can be
applied to the entire project.
But inside Cloud
IoT Core, we also
provide the ability to apply
these permissions-- or rules--
to specific device registries
or collections within a project.
So this is something where
you're applying Cloud IAM
to control who can access--
or who can perform certain
actions--
on Cloud resources
defined by Google
in a managed service
like Cloud Core.
The other thing
you can use IAM for
is controlling access to who
can publish to certain Cloud
Pub/Sub topics.
So Cloud IoT Core
and Cloud Pub/Sub
are very tightly integrated.
And by limiting who can
publish to certain topics,
you can constrain Pub/Sub
that only messages being
published by devices to IoT
Core arrive on a Pub/Sub topic.
And this is important because
that way you can use certain
attributes published by
IoT Core on messages--
such as a device ID--
and know that those
attributes were only
coming through devices.
And not through some other
cloud publisher online
that has access to
that Pub/Sub topic.
So it's one of the constraints
you can put on other systems
that IoT Core interacts with.
Now the title of his
talk is IOT and Firebase.
And Firebase is actually
a very large suite
of products and services.
And we're certainly not going
to cover them all today.
There is also the fact that a
number of these services now
sort of have dual
representations
in both the Firebase experience
and the Cloud GCP experience.
So the ones where it's
going to be touching on
ARE authentication hosting
Firestore and Cloud Functions.
So authentication is the kind
of customer identity management,
I'll get into that in a second.
Hosting is static hosting.
Firestore is a
document database.
And then Cloud Functions.
Again, this is the same
back end infrastructure
shared between Google Cloud
Platform and Firebase,
as far as executing
lightweight functions.
So the first is around
identity management.
So when Zoltan was talking
about the main components,
this is how you
manage your own users.
So when you do have
end users involved,
you need a way of
managing who they are.
This handles user
authentication,
recognizing that these
users exist in your system.
So when a developer logs
into Google Cloud Platform,
our Google identity
system is what
we expect infrastructure
users to be able to log into.
Now, you can integrate
that with AD, et cetera.
But that's identity
management for infrastructure
this is identity
management that we
offer-- as a service--
for you to incorporate
into your own applications.
And once you have
authentication--
then to address authorization--
this is where Firebase rules
that apply to Firestore
come in.
And this is a service
that allows applications
to communicate directly
to the database
without needing to go through
any sort of API middle tier.
And if you're going to have
applications talking directly
to a database, you need to
apply authorization logic.
And the way we do that is a we
have a service that basically
lets you describe
that authorization
syntax in your application.
And have the database
actually apply that for you.
So we'll get a little bit
more into some of the syntax
for these rules a little.
Later but let's talk about
the kind of architecture
we're going to show
and demonstrate, here.
And that is we've got
some devices on the left.
These are, kind of,
hypothetical-- sort of,
gas sensors in this
case-- we're going to use.
And then users end users
interacting with an application
on the right.
So the first thing
we do is we're
going to use Cloud IoT
Core to securely connect
the devices to the cloud.
And then on the
application side,
we're going to host
the static content
related to the application.
And deliver that to
users in an browsers
or mobile applications
from Firebase Hosting.
And then the live data
that the application
is going to be
interacting with is
going to come from Firestore.
But because Firestore
is directly connected
to the application, we're going
to make sure that fire still
rules are applied to the way
the application is getting data
in and out of Firestore.
Now to connect these two
for device sensor data,
we're going to use the
Cloud IoT Core's integration
with Pub/Sub.
And then Cloud Functions that
take readings from sensors,
and write them into Firestore.
We also could have chosen
other cloud platform database
products to do this.
For example, we could write
this sensor series data
in the Cloud Bigtable.
Very scalable way of doing
series data, to be honest.
In this case, it
would have also meant
we would have had to
replace the Firestore
rules with our own
authorization implementation.
So we're going to go with
the simple path, here.
And just use Firestore
because it gives us
that rules sort of value.
We're also going
to send information
from the device in the Firestore
about the current settings
and state of the device.
So this isn't necessarily
the sensor data.
But this might be other
current settings and values
that are on the device,
changing less often.
And then finally when a user
changes a setting in a device,
we need to get that
back out to the device.
So, again, we use a
Cloud Firestore trigger
to run a Cloud Function when
data changes in Firestore.
And that Cloud
Function, then, can
send the updated configuration
through IoT Core to the device.
So when you put it
all together, it
looks a little
something like this.
So what we're really
trying to leverage
here is using as many
server and managed services.
We've got direction data
flowing in both directions.
And then we've got static
content and data being served
to an end user application.
So the scenario for this
demo is going to be sort of,
a hypothetical technician
who needs to check out
a piece of equipment.
And here is my gas sensor
that we're going to use.
And what they're
going to end up doing
is connect to it
through a mobile app.
So I'm going to test the
demo gods, because I've
got an IoT device, a
tablet, and a demo laptop
all concurrently interacting
with our Wi-Fi saturated world.
So let me plug into this.
So if we can have
the demo system up.
Got it.
All right, we can go ahead.
I'm going to restart
the casting here.
So we can have the
look that has the--
and reconnect.
The AV guys loved our
requirements list for this one.
All right, so here's the tablet.
I'm going to launch this app.
So the first thing is, let
me go ahead and back out.
I'm going to log out.
This app really doesn't do
anything until you log in.
So when I log in with Google--
actually, maybe I'll just
keep it that way, honestly.
When I log in with Google, I've
already authorized this app.
So directly using it to
go to a list of devices
that are associated with me.
This is a new device,
so I've just kind of
checked this out of a
rack, say, a shared rack
at the technician.
And what's displayed on here,
is a code that says let me--
as an employee--
claim this device
so that I have sort of
exclusive control over it.
So if I add this claim ID,
and it's my favorite one
so I'm just going
to name it fave.
Most of you won't be able to see
this change but I'll hit claim.
And as long as the network is
still good and connect it here,
this now says claimed.
So the device has now
recognized that it's claimed.
So I'm going to go into
the detail view, here.
So when you see on that real
time live graph is Light Data--
Light Sensor Data--
coming from this device.
And that's coming through
that telemetry path
that I showed in
the architecture.
You also can see that there
are a set of configuration
settings, and that
is a tilt threshold.
And so what that
means is, I have
an angle set that if I tilt this
device past a certain range,
I get a beep.
Now as a user, if
I want to change
the tolerance of those tilt
settings, I can go ahead.
And in this app, I'm going to
narrow those down, let me just
actually narrow one side here.
Now when I hit Update, you
see a little spinner up
in the dialog?
That's actually letting
me know that it's
taken a moment for the settings
to get to the device and then
the device--
it's doing that again.
Well what you can see here, is,
I've narrowed the tilt setting
and now it's a lot more
sensitive, all right?
Let me see, we'll
go one more time.
We have enough time that I can--
if you bear with me we'll--
this is a relatively
older tablet
that I pulled out for
this particular thing.
So I think between
us and the stage.
So before it glitches again,
I'll do this one more time.
I'll change the setting
and I'll update it.
In fact, I'll do it
again, one more time.
I'll narrow this other
direction of tilt. Hopefully
I haven't put it
into a state of here.
We'll see here that
now, if I tilt this--
essentially what I'm tilting.
But what I want to
do is show you back
on the laptop, a little bit
about what's going on here.
So that progress
spinner is actually
giving the user of the
tablet an indication
that the settings have not
yet actually been verified
as received by the device.
So I change a
setting in the UI, I
update the setting that changes
data in Cloud Firestore.
That change of data
in Cloud Firestore
triggers a Cloud Function to run
and send the new settings down
to the device through IoT Core.
When the device
receives the settings
and applies them
to the tilt sensor,
that sends another state
update message back
through that other top pathway.
Which confirms the state
as updated in Firestore.
And only when do those
two data values reconcile,
does the spinner go away.
So when you saw me update
a setting in the tablet--
and you saw a spinner
for a moment--
that's actually a
sort of a full round
trip to the device and back,
confirming those settings.
I'm going to show
you a little bit more
about how these
Firebase rules apply.
Because these rules are what are
preventing one user from seeing
data from a device-- or
changing settings of a device--
while another user has
that device claimed.
And the syntax of these rules is
based around matching patterns
of a document in Firestore.
So, first of all, the outcome
of a rule is to allow--
or not allow-- a given device.
So, essentially, it's
denied by default.
And unless a matching
rule is found,
don't allow the user to
actually read or write data
from the database.
So you can see the operations
can be read or write.
There's actually also
update and delete.
And the main one I
want to point out
is the kind of
middle section, here.
So I'll go from the top, which
is that the first rule is
around letting a user basically,
update their own user's
profile, right?
And that makes sense unless the
request coming from the user
matches the profile
user's ID, you
can't update somebody
else's profile.
The second one is related to
the device record, itself.
So, in this case, we
want to allow a person
to create a new
record, if they're
going to be the first
to claim a device that
can have that entered.
They also can read and write
the settings for a given device.
Because that's where
the updating of settings
is being written to.
And then the telemetry path.
This is where we are
storing incoming sensors.
So that real time
line graph was going
to a telemetry collection.
Just to backup and give a little
bit more context for those
who don't know as much on
the Firestore of the document
database, documents are
organized into collection.
So, here, we're talking about
three different collections;
users, devices, and telemetry.
And the way Firestore
rules are applied,
is you can apply them only to
documents and collections that
match certain patterns.
In the case of the
middle one, here,
what we're doing is we're taking
the device ID-- which is also,
in this case, the document ID--
and using that as a
variable in the rule.
And just to show
you the way this
works from at the
actual database layer,
I have another user logged
in to the same system.
And since the URL path was
used for getting the data
from that device--
if I try to put in
that device URL--
you'll see that not only is it
being blocked at the web front
end logic, but if you look
at the developer console,
the permission error is actually
coming from the database,
right?
So if I didn't show you
this developer console,
it'd be very easy to
sort of say, oh, well,
this is authorization logic
happening in the application
in the front end.
That is subject to bugs,
and errors, and in the way
authorization is applied.
So, here, by seeing
the developer console,
I can show you that
this is actually
being enforced at the
Firebase client library
and back end integration point.
We don't need to
put the tablet up,
but I will go ahead and release
this device from this user.
And if I go back I
can now claim this.
And now I can see it.
And now I can actually get to
that URL for the detail view.
So that's how we're
able to use sort of,
the real time nature
Firestore to basically,
apply these rules based on the
data that's in the database.
I think that's the other key
takeaway for Firestore rules,
is that they are
applied per request--
per document-- in a way
that lets your own rules
and your own data
models in the database
be that custom application
layer of authorization.
So while IAM has a focus on
the resources-- or the models--
that are defined by
Google, if you're
defining the sort of application
objects in Firestore,
you can apply Firestore
rules in a custom way
to those objects in that data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]